hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you I'm just
checking in on it oh sorry I'm just
checking in on you to see now your weeks
going a little half-hour checking him
how you doing are you doing okay
fan-fucking-tastic you know it's funny
I'm always a day late and a dollar short
- [ __ ]
so I [ __ ] got a YouTube page now
we're doing all this animation I'm
[ __ ] hiring people that do stuff try
to get this [ __ ] thing going so
someday I won't even have to leave my
house all I got to do is just sit here
ramble and about crazy [ __ ] as I slip
into [ __ ] senility and I'll still be
able to eat my applesauce I'll still be
able to pay for some [ __ ] applesauce
all right that is what that is what the
old age is all about okay you don't
leave your house but checks are still
coming in okay you got a cupboard full
of [ __ ] applesauce once you open them
you put them in the fridge you know even
though it hurts your teeth oh right
because you got a [ __ ] nerve
involvement all you [ __ ] like it
teeth right you go back to eating the
same [ __ ] you see as a baby it's just
it's like applesauce is Gerber food for
[ __ ] old people right so you got that
what else do you have you mix a little
mayonnaise in there anything you don't
have to [ __ ] chew don't get the
YouTube page going and then you know
what these [ __ ] [ __ ] at YouTube do
now if you I can't even tell you at this
thing what they decide if what the [ __ ]
happened on your thing is is a little
too offensive like they [ __ ] decide
and then you don't get any of the ad
money and I'm like but the ads still
there who gets the money YouTube keeps
it [ __ ] unbelievable I'll tell you
right [ __ ] now the number one
commandment broken I'm telling you it's
stealing and there's more stealing that
goes on on the legal side of business
everybody's always making [ __ ]
Scorsese he's always doing that you know
if I go [ __ ] you
whenever that [ __ ] song is I could go
from rags to riches that's what the hell
it is right
all that Goodfellas [ __ ] [ __ ] you you
pay me [ __ ] you pay me all of that like
that doesn't exist in the legal world
it's even [ __ ] worse and it's more
overt that is just straight-up [ __ ]
stealing so I don't know what I'm gonna
do with the YouTube page I'm actually
thinking what if I don't just move it to
my [ __ ] website right I'll reach out
to [ __ ] millaa millaa High Life you
want to [ __ ] uh you want to [ __ ]
just be on all my videos and I'll just
do it on my page and I can do say
whatever the [ __ ] I want and not worry
about somebody taking my [ __ ]
retirement applesauce money it's not
making any [ __ ] money anyways you got
to have like a billion hits I think to
make seven dollars well you know you got
a curate Mimi is there talking to you
here like a cash machine going off in
the [ __ ] background whatever who
gives a [ __ ]
alright you know what I am actually in a
great mood here I am in a great mood and
um despite that highway robbery YouTube
she call it your tube your [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're keeping all the [ __ ]
money your [ __ ]
um who gives a [ __ ] right at the end of
the [ __ ] day well obviously you do
Billy you wouldn't have brought it up I
don't [ __ ] mind just just [ __ ] me
over
why can't you just [ __ ] me over why
can't you just come out and just say
listen we're gonna [ __ ] you over why do
you got a lie why do you gotta sit there
act like you're not gonna do it and then
you turn around do it that's what upsets
me it's not that you're doing it you
said you said you weren't gonna do it
alright anyways Brad Marchand suspended
for two games for stabbed and Jake
Dotson in the balls so he got one game
for each ball each ball that he [ __ ]
stabbed him in and that makes sense I
know a lot of people like why didn't
Sidney Crosby
because what Sidney did don't you see is
he turned his [ __ ] stick sideways and
he gave him a little tap a little tap of
the ball back like the same level that
when you know the doctor you go to get a
physical he as you cross your legs and
you know he hits you and your knee goes
up right just like that he was just
testing the guy's reflexes so he gets no
suspension or a penalty
you know plus he has those big pouty
lips and everybody feels bad for him
that's the genius of Sidney Crosby
Sidney Crosby has a look on his face you
know like right before you make your
girlfriend cry and then you're like oh
my god she's gonna cry so you just
abandon your argument like that's what
his face looks like so I think that's
why he's able that's why he's able to
get away with what he gets away with
plus you know he's a superstar he makes
everybody a ton of money so Brad
Marchand you know you live by the sword
you die by the sword
I remember branded press [ __ ] stabbed
him in the nuts when we will play in
Vancouver a couple of years ago and then
what's funny is to listen to Jack
Edwards when he sees Marshawn he's such
a [ __ ] Homer he sits in they go whoa
look at all that is blatantly out of the
rules that is a delicious video for the
boys in New York hope you enjoy your day
off yay talk on a definitely suspension
and uh and then Marshawn wave you know
[ __ ] just I mean he uppercutted this
dude's nuts his stick was not on the
flat side like he was giving it a
backhand or you know he did an uppercut
with the stick to the guy's taint and
ball area and like you know your wife
tells you to shovel the driveway and
you're already pissed at you you know
how hard you throw those first two
[ __ ] scoops of snow over your
shoulder that's how hard he hit this guy
in the [ __ ] nuts and I got to tell
you as a Bruins fan I thought I was like
oh my god he just [ __ ] us over because
he just got kicked out of the game I
think it was still zero to zero against
the the Tampa Bay Lightning and we were
waiting to UM you know to see if we were
going to make the playoffs I'm like oh
my god he just got give right at the end
of the first period I'm like he's gonna
get kicked out that's gonna [ __ ] you
know give Tampa a little jump until
they're dead game they're gonna win this
[ __ ] game he's going to be out for
the rest of the season and and then
we're gonna you know my catastrophize in
my head what if we [ __ ] you know
don't make the playoffs because of that
plan but fortunately we ended up winning
I think four to one or four to nothing
and if we beat Ottawa tonight we can
actually you know we the very least are
going to be a wild card but I mean I
don't obviously I don't feel like
playing [ __ ] the cap
right now they looking like world
beaters but eventually you will have to
plan but it'd be nice to maybe have a
chance to win a playoff series we'll see
how we do though you never know
goaltender's can get they get hot at the
right time of year there's no telling
how far you could go in the Stanley Cup
Playoffs um I feel like for me I just
feel that um that's actually become part
of my vocabulary now because every time
Nia watches those [ __ ] reality shows
people OHS go from me or to me I just
feel and now I've done it so much now
I'm doing it so I am officially Bill
Kardashian right now alright I'm not
thinking about transitioning I'm not
gonna die what's left of my [ __ ] eye
gotten like up ahead shade now by my
beard I'm not gonna dry diet [ __ ] jet
black you know but like a Kardashian I
did marry an African American so I feel
like I'm halfway there I think I could
actually say that I'm one of their
cousins I don't know oh I see a
Photoshop coming anyways to get back to
to the hockey um so yeah so we're in the
playoffs for the first time in three
[ __ ] years so it's great to be in
there and hopefully we'll be Ottawa
tonight and I bet mahjong caused himself
a little bit of [ __ ] money there you
know I would think in his contract that
he gets a bonus if he gets 40 goals and
the man was sitting on 39 we're going to
play Ottawa tonight forget about the
rest of the game that he could have
played in Tampa playing Ottawa tonight
and according to the puck off podcast
hosted by Joe bartnik on the all things
comedy network he said that uh ottawa's
got a lot of injuries in their defense
who knows who knows so I guess what you
take away from all of that is that if
you're in the NHL if you're gonna [ __ ]
hit somebody's ball bag you do it with
the flat side of the stick
alright you get yourself you know some
collagen injections India lips like a
Kardashian I don't know maybe they did
it didn't I don't know you know so you
look like you're about ready to cried
like Cyndi Crosby and you will not get
suspended alright but I actually heard
Crosby then I [ __ ] slash somebody and
almost took the end of his [ __ ] like
the guy's end of the guy's finger was
hanging off you know I'm gonna go out on
a limb and say that guy he's going to
they uh there's not really like any of
the goons anymore they have like that
that's like players like Crosby's to
just have like security like back in the
day in like the 80s like the [ __ ]
tough guys back in the 80s were like
they did everything but just have like
blue blazers on in earpieces standing
next to the goal scorers if you went
anywhere near them they'd [ __ ] murder
you and I'm trying to think of who the
Penguins have penguins never really had
a goon they had a bunch of [ __ ] knee
breakers they were really into like well
we're not going to fight you we're just
going to end your career blow out your
[ __ ] knee bored you and that type of
[ __ ] filthy filthy [ __ ] franchise but
you know the penguin is a dirty bird
isn't it sort of the pigeon of the
Antarctic isn't it do you guys hear
they're building some luxury condos down
there luxury condos in Antarctica you
know the people in Silicon Valley they
don't know where else to spend their
money they already bought up San
Francisco they're starting to come down
here to LA and for a summer place
because San Francisco so [ __ ] cold
that the next thing that they're going
to do they can be down in Antarctica you
can look it up it's true luxury condos
in Antarctica and LA to Antarctica
they're going to have the first direct
flight in July all of that is true I'm
not making this up at all because I have
a half hour to to fill up here and I'm
only 10 minutes and I would never do
that to you guys alright let's talk
about Oh Billy beefcake here all right
[ __ ] dad bod Magoo who after his
European run last summer was up to a
[ __ ] 190 pounds and then I kind of
started working out getting ready for my
special I got down like a buck 78
finished the special and are they really
specials anymore now that there's one
coming out every week it was just sort
of bill talks for an hour I think since
my special came out in January there's
been ninety seven other hour-long
specials I think there's been out one
out every day anyway so I I got down to
a buck seventy eight seventy nine ish
and uh and then I was just like all
right now I'm waiting to become a dad
you know my wife was in the third tribe
mr. so I'm gonna try meth so I'm gonna
[ __ ] blame her a little bit even
though I was just drinking too much
everything so I got up to like a backup
like a buck 85 buck 86 so now last week
I got myself down to 180 pounds this
week I wanted to lose at least two
pounds alright the weigh-in is tomorrow
but I'll just start doing them on
Thursday so I wanted to get down to 178
maybe 177 got on the scale today 170 7.6
alright so I am um I got one day on a
film coming up who aren't you fancy bill
yes I am I got one day out of film so
ultimately you know I need to be to not
get too much [ __ ] on Twitter about being
a big booze headed [ __ ] bald-headed
red [ __ ] you know which always [ __ ]
happens all these [ __ ] actresses
[ __ ] [ __ ] moan and complaining like
the internet has only mean to them I
swear to god [ __ ] self-involved
lunatics right I got to get down to like
my fight and waits usually about a buck
72 on camera if I walk around a buck 75
you know if you just see me coming down
the street I mean I look radiant okay
you're gonna look at me like Jesus bill
are you expecting look at that look on
your face
[ __ ] with you but I got to get but on
camera I got to be down to a buck 72
alright and every [ __ ] actor knows
what [ __ ] wait you got to be it so
you know and you all get all you just
gauge it on social media feedback cuz
you're just going to get a ton of [ __ ]
the second you go a little power dude
you look like Vince Vaughn and the end
of the [ __ ] the break-up you know
that was my favorite part of that
[ __ ] move I love that [ __ ] movie I
loved how Vince did the [ __ ] he had
the not in a relationship [ __ ] you
know out there crushing ass and then
when he was in the relationship he had
that extra 10 to 15 you know the Netflix
wait let's sit here and you know make
some mac and cheese and play footsie I
don't ruin the end of the movie but uh
that that's one of the best you know and
that was a chick flick too because it
was about a relationship and that's one
of my favorite things about it was it
played out in a real way right down to
the you know when he's not in a
relationship he's [ __ ] you know he's
at his fighting weight
you know I'm trying to attract somebody
to [ __ ] me again okay you were a layup
so I had my layup extra fifteen on right
that's what I'm trying to lose right now
Oh Billy layup wait so I'm down to 170
seven point six so next week the
official weigh-in is on Friday but I'll
do them on Thursday just to give just
add a little excitement in your life
because I'm so self-involved I feel like
you guys actually give a [ __ ] so do it
with me lose two pounds this week at
least if not three so I want to be down
to about a buck 74 by Friday next week
and then we shoot the following week so
I could actually be down to 173
you know if I puke behind a dumpster you
know take the old [ __ ] you know you
know what root I guess you can't even
say you can't even say bulimia without
people freaking out unless you're like
it's one of the worst of these you can't
even use it as a comedy reference are
you allowed to are you allowed to say
you know use that as a reference like
I'll go go if I have to if I have to I
will make myself [ __ ] yak for [ __ ]
a day to get down to the buck 72 to
deliver my line and a half on this movie
[Laughter]
Gober king of the line and a half if you
got a line and a half that you need to
[ __ ] be delivered by a tertiary
character did I use that word correctly
I am your [ __ ] man I will show up on
time in shape ready to [ __ ] work I'll
show up at my fighting weight of 172 I
will deliver that line I'll even give
you a look all right if you give me like
a special and special appearance by Bill
burr and the opening credits whatever
the [ __ ] that's called I will actually
throw in I'll give you I'll give you the
rock you know with one of my invisible
eyebrows that you can't really see um
yeah anyway so I'm gonna get down to
that I'm gonna get down to hopefully
like a book whatever semitte whatever
look at me I sound like the [ __ ] Rain
Man but that's the only way to do it and
eventually I'd like to get down to what
a buck 68 okay and then not do what I
always do to be like oh I'm a buck 68
you know who wants some [ __ ] cookies
let's get a [ __ ] 12-pack you know and
then I just I slowly but surely go right
back up and I I have to make a lifestyle
change I just feel like for me
I'm gonna be a lot happier if I cut out
gluten and I still don't know what
gluten is it's some sort of chemical
that's in wheat I believe and evidently
it's not good for you even though wheat
is from the earth but you know there are
poisonous plants or is gluten like some
[ __ ] that some [ __ ] nerds made for
psychopaths that have food companies
that adds to the density or some [ __ ]
and somehow they make more money is that
what it is they're always looking to do
that [ __ ] you know what I mean you can't
[ __ ] satisfy these [ __ ] lunatic
these [ __ ] guys did the men at the
top of these corporations you know what
they're like they're like a bunch of
[ __ ] brats you don't mean like no
matter what they have they never [ __ ]
happy you know you got straight hair now
you want curly hair now you want short
hair you know then you want to wear a
crop top now you want to [ __ ] you
know have clam diggers on I don't what
the [ __ ] it is you do it can you just
put on a [ __ ] pair of sweatpants and
just sit down for five [ __ ] minutes
you know Howard my wife would be
laughing at this [ __ ] right now cuz I'm
the one who I [ __ ] look I look like
this is supposed to be my relaxed energy
right now and I'm still talking too fast
whenever I listened back to my podcast
I'm like why why do I talk so fast I
thought I would I thought I'd talked a
lot slower I need to have like cocktail
party energy now even a cocktail party
you gotta yell you gotta yell over
people right I don't know a cocktail
party just call it what it is we're
getting away from our kids to get
shit-faced for a few hours
alright and somebody's gonna try to
dominate the conversation
somebody's gonna [ __ ] bring up
politics someone's gonna get too drunk
then there's gonna be a [ __ ] argument
then there's got to be apologies
afterwards why doesn't everybody just
pick a [ __ ] corner of the room okay
stare at the carpet and just just start
drinking okay that's it why else are we
here is this some swingers party we're
gonna trade off here like what what is
going on
I don't Maggie I don't give a [ __ ] about
your worldview you don't hold public
office you do not have access to
top-secret documents in the Pentagon so
at the end of the day what am I doing
here
aren't I really listening to like a
nurse trying to tell me how to fix a car
isn't that kind of the same thing would
you like to hear what I think about
[ __ ] the Middle East of course you
wouldn't well I'll write that finish
your [ __ ] drink um anyways uh what
else is going on this weekend oh I'm
gonna be in I'm gonna be in San Antonio
but not one show but two two shows at
the Majestic Theatre oh my god it's so
majestic they added a second show I'm
gonna be doing some morning radio
tomorrow to hype that second show um
doing not one show I'm doing two shows
like Brad Marchand I'm not gonna [ __ ]
stab you in one ball I'm stabbing in two
not gonna get suspended for one game
you're suspended I'm gonna do one show
for every game Brad Marchand was
suspended okay was unfairly targeted
because he in a moment of emotion he
used the shoveling the snow [ __ ]
technique and he did not have the Sidney
Crosby pouty lips for when he went to
the board in New York I think that's
what Crosby does you know he just he
doesn't have to go to New York they just
[ __ ] put him on skype and he just
said say like hi guys I'm sorry you know
it's just having a bad period oh isn't
it amazing how much I could talk without
even knowing what the [ __ ] um I don't
know what I'm talking about here um hey
you guys want to know how to change a
shitty diaper properly are there any
parents out there here's one to grow on
here's one of my ears a tip for you all
right what happens is is when you have a
little bass say the word say the goddamn
[ __ ] word you're gonna be okay
uh if you have a baby and you're
breastfeeding it as opposed to giving it
formula I'm staying away from that [ __ ]
I just I don't like that [ __ ] name
formula at that [ __ ] name alone I'm
not giving my baby formula you know I
was just pictured like when those
Frankenstein movies with the graduated
cylinder the dry out dry ice smoke
coming out of the top of it so anyway so
they bait yeah they got a liquid diet
going on so when you know when the
[ __ ] back door comes off the hinges
as they say uh you know this is the deal
the second you hear the [ __ ] you know
the rumblings and the grumblings what
you got to do is you got to get your kid
not horizontal you got to have them
upright alright now this is the problem
when you take them down to the changing
table when you lay them back down again
okay and you taken off the onesie you
got to elevate them a little bit you
know as they say [ __ ] runs downhill okay
so what you want to do is you want to
use gravity as a favour this it's a
two-person job if you're going to save
that [ __ ] onesie alright what you got
to do is you have to have the baby
[ __ ] standing up on the changing
table alright the other person undoes
the onesie lifts the onesie up over the
[ __ ] diaper and then you take the
diaper off like you're taking the
transmission out of a car that's up on a
lift alright then you use gravity
everything drops down I'm trying to be
as not graphic as humanly possible okay
then you know then you begin the [ __ ]
the restoration because I'm telling you
right now if you're home alone alright
and you lay that kid down then what [ __ ]
runs downhill now what's on the onesie
you got to take it off you got to go
over the kids [ __ ] head and now you
got [ __ ] on the [ __ ] oh I'm sorry and
this is what it is I don't want to put
[ __ ] on the kid's head tell you it's a
rough one you know so fortunately if
that [ __ ] happens is somebody else
around I'm sorry I didn't mean to get
that graphic but
you know people who are parents I'm
telling you just one person holds it up
you undo the onesie you drop the diaper
out like a [ __ ] transmission you know
do a little cleanup then you [ __ ] set
the kid down then you finish the [ __ ]
cleanup BAM a new diaper actually you
don't even do that usually we just bring
her into the [ __ ] shower and start
all over again
with a brand new squeaky-clean [ __ ]
kit and there you go there's a little
parental assited parental advice okay I
just felt like for me I just felt like
it needed to be said is anybody watching
that reality show black ink my wife
watches it all the time there is a woman
on there that makes my temper look like
a [ __ ] summer breeze
good lord does she lose her [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's like she's possessed um I actually
just literally have to walk out of home
but I know I keep forgetting this this
show I started to watch I watched the
first three episodes and I absolutely
[ __ ] loved it and I tweeted about it
it was a cartoon from Japan I guess
they're called anime which I did know
that but I didn't realize it was such a
divisive thing to say that you like to
show that was anime I feel like is anime
like the emo of [ __ ] cartoons like I
tweeted that I like this show called one
punch man alright and the [ __ ]
responses that I got I got dude you
[ __ ] drunk oh my god you're into ma
and then other people just like this
it's like the craziest day ever
I just liked the show I've watched
enough for the same type of [ __ ] and I
was scrolling through and I was like
what the [ __ ] is this show and I looked
and it had five stars four and a half
five stars which is why I really hope
Netflix doesn't go - thumbs up thumbs
down like I said because it's so [ __ ]
you know stubbing your toe thumbs down
Adolf Hitler thumbs down I mean the
thumbs down his system there's a big gap
between Hitler and yeah you know
stopping your [ __ ] tope um anyway so
I put this thing on and what I loved
about the show
assignment of fact I really thought it
was funny that you actually kind of got
like a sense of what young people feel
like in Japan as far as their view of
going into the corporate world was very
similar to the empty feeling unless
you're a [ __ ] sociopath over here I
find like a very like common thread to
that and to basically give the overall
thing the superhero in it he's not a
supe he doesn't want to be a superhero
alright and he [ __ ] trained really
hard because he want to be the strongest
guy in the world and in his training he
lost all his hair which is hilarious and
he's really self-conscious about it but
he ended up developing like this punch
and no matter what monster he runs into
he doesn't give a [ __ ] whether they kill
him he's just completely devoid of any
like passion or emotion like what
happens to you when you get shoved into
a [ __ ] cubicle and and he's got this
one punch and he just [ __ ] can punch
so hard that no matter how [ __ ]
bad-ass the monster is he gives him one
somebody said they should have called
the shoulder right there Fred he gives
him the [ __ ] fire in the [ __ ] in
the face is eddie murphy says in the
face and their [ __ ] head explodes and
the monsters that he fights you also get
more of an insight into where people's
heads arrive in japan and it was like
you know one of the monsters he fought
with some giant virus sent here by the
earth to get rid of the all the humans
because of what we've done to the planet
so there was environmental thing then my
favorite one was this guy who was crab
man he was half like up top and he was
all a crab and then the bottom he was he
was half a guy and he was in put the
bottom half he's in his bare feet and
tighty whities and the guys like oh i
ate so much crab meat that I became a
[ __ ] crab and to me he represented
the upper 1% corporate guys you know on
some Power Lunch just eating all the
[ __ ] sushi and just take take take
take take nothing spiritual about him so
he gave him the old right there Fred and
then he fought this [ __ ] leg and she
had command of all the mosquitos and
she'd SiC the mosquitos on everybody
suck all the blood out of you and all
your [ __ ] energy and then it would
make her
stronger and to me it's like oh this is
a gold-digging blood-suckin [ __ ] right
and then once she got it to do it to all
the animals and everybody there she
didn't need the mosquitoes anymore she
told all the mosquitoes to go [ __ ]
themselves and I'm like slash this is
also somebody who becomes successful and
forgets where they come from and they
look at everybody where they used to be
as like a bunch of [ __ ] peons
a bunch of little insignificant little
mosquitoes right it's a lot of levels to
it or you can just get [ __ ] high and
watch this bald-headed dude [ __ ]
punch half a crab in the head and watch
it explode I enjoyed it
alright let's do a little [ __ ]
advertising here before I wrap up and I
talked about MotoGP and the f1 Chinese
Grand Prix and my glutes alright Luke
rate everybody give me to them are you
on a quest for an app for epic gear
housewares and collectibles oh do you
have a one-punch man t-shirt this is
finally going to [ __ ] make sense to
me loot crate has it the best surprise
you know is coming Luke rate offers an
epic range of pop-culture items for less
than $20 a month if you're more of a
fanatical fashionista than a then try
loot where monthly wearables and
accessories with Koch classics and your
favorite franchises do you want to get
fancy get a bigger box with a with even
bigger loot with loot crate DX want to
geek out your pet try loot pets offer
expires April 19th and 9 p.m. Pacific
for April join us as we salute one of
our favorite mystery solvers with items
from strangers things Batman The X Files
and Marvel's Jessica Jones do get some
one-man punch [ __ ] in there one lucky
subscriber will also win a mega crate
including signed copies of Jessica Jones
alias volumes 1 through 4
Oh Jessica Jones alias volumes 1 through
4 I'm not like I might as well be
reading a different language I have no
idea what any of this [ __ ] is other than
stranger things and I know Batman and I
used to know this chick named Jessica
you have until the 19th at 9 p.m.
Pacific he just said this to subscribe
to receive that month's crate and when
the cutoff happens that's it it's
go to Luke Raycom / burn enter my code
birbee you are are to save $3.00 off any
new subscription today all right here we
go here we go how many of these [ __ ]
things I got to read all right lift
everybody ly L to the [ __ ] yft
you know about lift right it's the app
that gets you a ride in minutes
on-demand 24/7 for less than the cost of
a cab please include all the following
points during your read well if it takes
too long I'm not if you tried lifts you
know what I mean
with lifts you got you just download the
app requested driver and they show up in
three and a half minutes on average
that's really fast you know unless
there's a [ __ ] guy chasing you with
an axe and that's probably takes forever
every lyft driver is fully vetted
through their ten-point safety standard
including criminal and DMV background
checks you know you'll get around
quickly and safely other than that other
one ah that rhymes with müber lifts
drive drivers are rated after every ride
so the only the best stick around you
don't have to worry about getting into a
filthy car with some creepy dude with
lifts you can tip in the app which
obviously leads to happier drivers I
mean 9 out of 10 lift rides get a
perfect 5 star rating from the passenger
it's just a better all-around experience
bigger isn't always better
lyft isn't the biggest riding
ride-sharing app but it's the fastest
growing and the highest-rated one I'm
talking about quality over quantity
thanks to lift you got an easy way to
avoid drunk driving you never have to
bum a ride you never have to worry about
parking a lot of people are actually
getting rid of their cars and relying on
lyft to get around and you know what I
don't blame them evidently right now
lyft is offering our listen as a special
offer deal get three rides up to ten
dollars each there's a up to a thirty
dollar
[ __ ] dollar value on you enter promo
code bill Barker
well people don't listen this [ __ ]
long that's promo code bill burr enter
promo code bill burr cut to the [ __ ]
chase 21 alright
helix everybody so one punch [ __ ]
reference alright
helix helix I don't know you're unique
you're a special little snowflake take a
bath and reconnect with yourself you
don't walk like anyone else top lock
anyway
now change it or sleep like anyone else
so why is your mattress
one-size-fits-all I don't know because
there's an average height of a human
being because it truly customized
mattress will cost you five to ten
thousand bucks whoo I didn't know that
until now go to HELOCs helix sleep calm
answer a few simple questions and
they'll run a 3d biomechanical model of
your body through their proprietary
algorithms they've developed with the
help of the world's leading arigon aaahm
except I Oh mechanics experts the
results there's a [ __ ] robot that
looks like you walking around blowing
Donald Trump and eventually they get rid
of you but in the meantime you're
sleeping on the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept on he likes
sleep
he likes customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality how
do you tell how do you I guess when you
wake up in the morning how much better
you feel and for cups customers you know
what happens is when you're sleeping
right when you're going to do the survey
that robot that they made a you comes in
and [ __ ] jerks you off while you
sleep and you wake up like oh my god I'm
so [ __ ] relaxed and then once you
give the approval rating that robot
leaves that's it that's how they do it
in four couples they customize each side
of the mattress your mattress arrives at
your door in about a week and shipping
is pretty 100% free that's why everyone
from GQ magazine's to Forbes are all
talking about helix sleep Alex you have
100 nights to try it out and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free
Ross and give you 100% refund no
questions asked go to hellix leat comm /
/ and get $50 off your order
that's helix sleep calm / / hellix sleep
calm / / alright lastly but not leastly
oh this is great I'm trying to lose
weight I have to do this
blue apron everybody not all ingredients
are created equal
fresh high-quality ingredients make a
real difference so it's important to
know where your food comes from talk
about your personal exposure talk about
your personal experience or the white
camellia cook the ingredients all all
how our treasured heartfelt cooking
attractor if you don't do this we will
not give you any [ __ ] our money miss my
experience every time I read it I want
to try it I've never done it they sent
me a gift card I'd used the gift card
but I don't like going on the internet
trying to figure out [ __ ] I put it on my
wife's desk I'm hoping at some point
she's going to come across it and that
she will get it and at some point some
quinoa
up wrapped in a blue apron that's my
experience additional points featured as
desired feature as desired I'll die like
this I get I got if I get choices here
for less than $10 per person per meal
blue apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre-portioned ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meals choose
from a variety of new set recipes each
week or let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you recipes are not repeated
within a year so you'll never get bored
customize your [ __ ] recipes each
week's based on your preferences blue
apron has several delivery options so
you can choose the one that fits your
needs maybe you can have your [ __ ]
helix robot show up and give you your
goddamn couscous and there's no weekly
commitment so you get deliveries
whenever you want them each meal comes
with step-by-step they'll show you how
to cook it you can have it done in 40
minutes or less - [ __ ] healthy you're
going to get your abs people will be
able to see your abs everybody has abs
if you didn't have abs you couldn't set
up in bed
alright check out to watch your robot
just running out the door did I just
dream that check out this week's menu
and get your first 3 meals for free with
free shipping by going to blue apron com
/ / you will love how good it feels
and taste to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue aprons so do
not wait unless you want to that's blue
apron com / / blue apron blue apron a
better way to cook that's the only way
to deliver that line that's why they
have the call me you have to pause
that's old-school advertising you can't
say blue apron a better way to cook you
got to be like blue apron a better way
to cook ok bill on this take on this
date did you discover the word blue
apron is it like like oh I didn't know
that was there yeah I could do that can
I give you three different reads yeah
that would be great
ok here we go blue apron a better way to
cook blue apron a better way to cook
blue apron a better way to cook how is
that no swagger we got it ok we'll see
you next week all right thank you yeah
susie-wusie Chloe um anyways let me get
back to sorry I was just giving you guys
a little behind the scenes on voice
overs did you like that did you feel
like you were there alright let me wrap
this up this weekend I'm for the first
time I think I'm gonna watch an entire
MotoGP race I believe it's an Argentina
it's somewhere down south uh oh yeah I'm
all shook up
no further south than that oh it's good
coach going a little samba action who
the [ __ ] I'm getting texts from right
now oh my god
I remember that person a minute alright
anyways MotoGP and then the Chinese
Grand Prix this is this is a very great
weekend before the the NFL and NBA
Playoffs start if you would like to
watch some alternative sports sports
that are not as big as the big four here
in the United States of American hookahs
kidding who our country matters the most
therefore our sports matter the most all
right
people know our star athletes around the
world
nobody knows people in the Premier
League you know the only reason why we
knew that one Fed Beckham guys because
they made a movie about it he was [ __ ]
one of the Spice Girls alright if he
wasn't [ __ ] some chick in a girl band
nobody knew who that guy was okay we
matter the most all right look let's try
to have a little more empathy as
Americans here let's watch some [ __ ]
great sports from around the world
MotoGP if you want to watch a bunch of
lunatics driving about 180 miles an hour
right next to each other taking turns
[ __ ] maniacs and also the technology
in that sports you know like those suits
now I don't know how they figure it out
but they figure out that the rider's
fallen off the bike and before he hits
the pavement pavement
ideally like the the suit that they wear
has like an airbag that just [ __ ]
immediately inflates and protects all
their vitals in theory you know
obviously I don't know if you [ __ ]
slam into a wall I don't know what
happens then but and then the Chinese
Grand Prix the second race the second of
20 races there's only 20 races it's very
easy to watch this and continue to watch
all the other sports that you love you
can tape it you can just
I can watch it and the Ferraris won the
first one was Sebastian Vettel I believe
and uh you know I'm sorry I'm sure
[ __ ] uh the [ __ ] his name Lewis
Hamilton is not happy about that [ __ ]
and I was actually going to go to that
TT race this year in the Isle of Man and
ended up [ __ ] falling apart so I got
to go next year I got to go next year
before they make it [ __ ] safe I have
to go and if you've never seen that race
more people have died than years that
they've had it did balls these people
have it's like [ __ ] real live Mad Max
type [ __ ] except they're still running
water and all that stuff
anyways alright let me talk about my
glutes giving this is something I
realized as I'm rehabbing all these
injuries in my body is that through
years of sitting on planes and sitting
on cars like I [ __ ] I have like no
glute muscles whatsoever like beyond the
usual [ __ ] white guy no ass type of
[ __ ] it's just like my [ __ ] thighs do
all the work so I've been I've been
doing these squats where you kind of
push them from your heels and when I'm
coming down and I'm trying to have most
my weight on my squat all my squats on
my heels with my torso like straight up
and down not leaning forward to
counterbalance the lack of glute muscle
that I have I start to come down into a
seating position I have to do it like
over my workout bench because if I just
try to go you know mainly depending on
my glutes I will literally fall down
like the first 30 degrees I'm okay and
then I just fall down to the bench so I
got to get that going
that's what I've been doing I just went
on and I looked up the top 10 include
things so I'm doing alternative leg
lunges I got an exercise ball up against
the wall that I put on my back and I go
all the way down to a deep squat pushing
up through my heels then I do the one
where you lay on your back your feet are
planted on the ground and then you lift
your hips up you know with your gluts
that way it's almost like you're you're
you're sort of thrusting up as if you
were [ __ ] somebody you know what I
mean but way up like they were lighter
than air and you could actually possibly
do that so I do those and then I do the
alternative [ __ ] leg lunges that's
what I'm doing so far so hopefully I
don't know I had no idea my body was
so goddamn [ __ ] up but evidently it is
but I am 177 point six so I'm very
excited about that and do with me
everybody come on the summer's coming up
lose a couple pounds a week let me cut
out the chips the cookies just [ __ ]
drink waters sign up for that blue apron
[ __ ] you know have a robot come and
deliver it to your house be done eating
by five six o'clock at night and even if
you get home later just I always try to
go like [ __ ] at least twelve hours
without eating when I'm trying to lose
weight for like the last day like if I
finish eating around seven I'm not going
to breakfast till like [ __ ] nine if
you do have a day job just have like
gonna and like a lighter breakfast or
something like that I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about all I can
tell you is what works for me alright
that's the podcast I have a great
weekend you [ __ ] check out some of them
and you know what else is on this
weekend the [ __ ] man umm the one golf
tournament that I really try to watch
every year it starts today so just um
you know if you don't watch the last
couple of [ __ ] games of hockey you
know I know baseball's going in that
type of stuff but I don't know there's
racing stuffs pretty [ __ ] goddamn
cool alright that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll see you on Monday
so fuzzy is completely addicted to
skating now and he wants to get better
at it and so we're [ __ ] in Edmonton
the next morning we got a drive down to
Calgary and Percy's going like there's
got to be a place here to skate so we
find out they have they have a skating
rink at the mall and not only is it a
mall it's one of the most giant malls in
North America America yeah West Edmonton
rivaling what's that one in Minnesota
Mall of America
Mall of America yeah yeah yeah so which
I've been to that one too so we go to
that one we're walking through there
with their [ __ ] skates two
middle-aged guys walking through this
thing with [ __ ] skates and we walk in
there's like this giant pirate ship I
mean like yeah you could sail the
[ __ ] ocean with this [ __ ] thing
yeah it was a [ __ ] official and I
look on the other side it was really
deep water and they took all this time
to make it look like there was a
shipwreck yeah Jesus cry me like you
could [ __ ] you know was monstrous man
like Shaq could drown in this water he
didn't that's how [ __ ] deep it was
huge and then we look on the other side
and I'm like Paul mcij that a [ __ ]
sea lion
they had sea lions at this thing they're
like thrown at fish fish and it was
catching trainer was don't it wasn't
like people just walking by throwing
[ __ ] from the food court it was a
trainer throwing it and so we're just
walking through the mall walking through
the mall endless [ __ ] mall they had a
water park there yeah it was since I
didn't look at any stores I was too
distracted by the [ __ ] in the middle and
then we finally get all the way to the
ice palace that called it ice palace and
we got all excited and we're the only
people with skates just walking through
holding a [ __ ] dumb skates when we
get all the way to the other side Rosy's
all excited like dude I'm I'm telling
I'm gonna get better at this you wait I
was getting ready this summer he's
already talking [ __ ] they're gonna
calling it right now I'm gonna be
[ __ ] skating backwards you're gonna
be like what the [ __ ] happened virzi
Yeah right and then we show up and
there's a big judo tournament where the
ice rink is and they'd [ __ ] put all
this floor flooring all over Thailand
look maybe this isn't a rink they might
acknowledge the ability to dude it says
ice palace ball this is it they covered
it up this is it I got upset though at
the mom a member net girl man I really
bothered me we're walking through the
food court and you know I we had a gyro
great gyro as you play
yeah yeah at great gyro at this place
called Jimmy the Greek the one complaint
and you agree a little too much white
sauce and was pasty yeah it wasn't it
wasn't yeah I was a little pasty just
about one scoop he went to want one
scoop lesson a little hot sauce oh no
what about excited he got excited it
would have been epic yeah well you got
excited so I said to Bill you know I
like a little dessert after I you know I
like a little candy bar I like a little
you know so I know sugar needs like so
so I go bill man there was the frozen
yogurt place I go yeah pink barrier some
icicles go frozen yoga see alright so
we're walking like I hate the picture so
two middle-aged men with skates I know I
don't like how you keep saying I'm
middle-aged you are middle-aged I'm 30 I
just turned 35 35 times to 70 most guys
[ __ ] drop my core I call like I call
middle it yeah alright what would you
call it no I guess you're right I guess
you know I always just when I thought of
it as a kid I always felt you know was
it no I don't know I just remember dude
I it's I don't know won't say 40 40s but
I Ian up boardies forty people do people
live long yeah dude I'm [ __ ] me 46 46
times two is 92 you're gonna really look
I can't really sit there and say I'm
middle-aged tell you the way I'm eating
and smoking you know no so so we walk
through and we're like where's that
where was that frozen yogurt place let's
go to that frozen yogurt place so we
took we see two young women walk by and
we figure hey I looked at them and I'm
like these these these ladies they're
gonna know we're if they're gonna know
we're a Pinkberry is so we walk up and
you go first you say to the friend you
go hey you got you guys know what that
could that good-looking too by the way
yeah good good-looking girls and you go
up first you but hey you guys know where
the frozen yogurt places and like she
did like a double take like she did it
double take so [ __ ] rude right and
she just was like what and then I looked
at the other one and I go yeah like a
Pinkberry and she kind of just like
gives a shake off like how would I know
like why you and she [ __ ] did this is
what she did she did the classic pretty
girl you're clearly just asking me this
because you want to talk to me thing and
I'm like no [ __ ] I want some [ __ ]
yogurt okay I want [ __ ] I want to
[ __ ] treat you no I just had lunch
and and it really bothered me dude and
we were walking around and I wanted to
find her I
today walk past us again they did the
loop on the fight I didn't know that but
I said to Bill when we got to the car I
wanted to find her cuz I woulda just
went up to her go you know something I
found it you're a mean jerk and then you
go why would you do that you're a mean
jerk that's terrible what am I gonna
call her a [ __ ]
well don't call her anything if you're
gonna go with mean jerk I mean you know
I hate that you're a girl mentality that
pretty girls that you're mean but you're
a jerk if you want to stay clean but if
you go you're a mean jerk no you're not
you're not you're not pretty inside
you're not pretty inside doesn't give a
[ __ ] she's a hot girl at the mall Paul
put yourself in her [ __ ] pumps all
right we're to [ __ ] lock her jackasses
standing there with ice skates when
there's a judo tournament down the way
asking if they know where the [ __ ] the
ice cream store is they looked at us the
way they were supposed to I you know
what dude I like a sweetheart yeah I
don't care I would love to hear them
tell this story and me coming in it's
just creepy guy comes up look good you
know what they are yeah you know yeah
but that's the way they're gonna hear it
Paul Paul you ever watch those [ __ ]
prison shows which ones like the scared
straight no not those ones where they
talk about the worst prisons in the
country and that type of [ __ ] oh yeah I
seen a couple of yeah and you just sit
there watching it going how the [ __ ]
would I go in there and not get raped
what would my game plan he gets scared
watching it in your bedroom right women
have to walk out of the house worried
about that that somebody's gonna you
know do just imagine if dude I had a
winter hat on with a puffy ball on top
of it holding ice skates asking for
yogurt Gaby if anything she probably
thought I was [ __ ] gay you don't look
gay Paul I know but with you're not
you're not question not you your beards
to terrorists you're you need to get a
little more metrosexual I'm gonna do
that we would switch sweatpants on do we
were a mess everybody in the [ __ ]
girl yeah that's what you love my beer
my beard actually [ __ ] says everybody
on the [ __ ] ground no but dude I I
don't like the pretty girl who can't be
approached with a question because oh
this guy's hitting on me it's it's awful
and you know something the gut
especially the blonde one who went like
shook her head like what she's gonna be
a nightmare she's a [ __ ] nightmare
for some future guy I'm telling you
she's an
man she's already selfish it's over what
if she just knows what she wants and
we're not it oh this is the thing dude
you actually allowed like how old do you
think they were probably 21 22 yeah you
let at 21 22 year old I met a girl at my
age not even a one way she shaking all
leather you let her ruin like dude we're
driving down to Calgary yeah she ruins I
got the Rocky Mountains on the
right-hand side of the car and you're
just still calling you're calling her a
[ __ ] the whole way down and fathered the
[ __ ] out of me it was like why you why
would you ask me how would I know
dude you realize how funny that is that
they did that to us like what like yeah
they really made us feel like [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] hilarious if you look at
it and father and the whole time is cuz
you wanted to get frozen yogurt dude how
funny would it be if we chased him down
and I when you got frozen yogurt with
sugarfree gummy bears ha it was still
all natural no organic gummy bears how
great would it be if we chased him down
and I just walked up to her and I go you
know something you hurt my feelings
I just [ __ ] broke down you know you
hurt my feelings I just wanted yogurt oh
by the way people listening here this is
last week you know you know just trying
to kill just trying to make jokes do not
go out of your mind being on tour this
[ __ ] long yeah is we were doing the
Dangerfield everything I'll tell you
gonna front of my love yogurt you know
so we were doing that and once that went
away that got old somewhere along the
line you started doing it you started
saying really sentimental [ __ ] to me and
then pretending like you were crying and
then that just became like the running
joke and then you started laughing and
then you were just like you got to do
that on stage do that crying thing so
now we'll just go up and like if we'll
be like hey man I'm tired but dude you
know what hanging with you on the road
has been great you're the only one I
could have done it with and then bill
would come and tag it
that's the best thing bill would come
and check it out you like hello I was
hoping you're gonna say that
falooda it's been it's been [ __ ]
wonderful for my anger I'm gonna try to
do that when I get home you'll attend
like I'm crying man it's [ __ ]
hilarious so two stories we go in to eat
and we have this Filipino waiter right
by the way I like to play the games
where I saw the hell where we was that
Edmonton was that Calgary that was
Evanston
yeah it was Evanston so I like to do
this thing where sometimes I like to
[ __ ] with people so I'll just get on a
phone and I'll be like bill go along
with it and we'll be in an elevator and
I'll go what no that's horseshit and
like bill just look what happened so
like I said like yeah the parole officer
called and he said in bill goes all they
worked it up and then instantly burgos
yeah but what about that videotape I go
no no they said it since immiscible and
like and like they got if there's just a
stranger there right sometimes I break
out laughing so bill calls it he gets a
little emotional guy so we turn this
crying thing we do it too like this has
been great right we turn we turn that
into doing it in public so we have this
Filipino waiter right and the whole guy
guy was great he was talking to us and
at the end I just go he goes out here's
your bill and I go I just want to say so
and I kept a dead straight face like
you've been a great waiter man okay and
I put my hand on his [ __ ] arm and I
got you know you're bringing the waters
you just a bill just looks at him go so
he gets a little it gets a little
emotional you know I mean I could not
but it's big it means a lot guy didn't
know like that though I had no because
he was so [ __ ] polite and he was
actually from the Philippines
so he's in doing you jumped right in
perfect lead a friend he gets a little
emotional I cannot but Billy he'd bring
the waters I'll do two he was freaked
out though well that's the new game on
the road you had the best on I gotta say
the best one was at the airport
yesterday we go to the airport yesterday
and Bill starts busting my balls about
my laundry and he goes virzi [ __ ] 16
days in you're carrying you know dirty
socks and underwear and I go dude I go I
bought new ones you know the dirty ones
are tied up tight in a plastic bag and
bill just goes just like your emotions
and dude I [ __ ] could not walk I
couldn't walk and I had to stop pulling
my [ __ ] point the bag I checked
cuz we were laughing so hard and I did
work style makes it makes it [ __ ]
great it's driving our tour manager nuts
oh yeah that's the one - yeah well
because women don't want to see a guy
getting emotional like that it's just
well no cuz once somebody right it's
over yeah like when I go out afterwards
and I'm taking pictures with people and
stuff I always come back I was just
saying I got to tell you you know you
I've seen a lot of people do that you
know doing the picture thing but you
gotta be one of the best Oz wives she's
going would you stop [ __ ] doing that our
wives are gonna go nuts cuz you know the
first thing I when I see stays and you
see your wife we're just gonna go it's
been so long it's just so much no you
got it you gotta set it up with talking
like you got to start off normal right
there you gonna say something really
sentimental to him so they're almost
crying and then you cry which ruins
their crying and I swear to god you get
slugged in the shoulder which is all you
really want
oh [ __ ] 20 minutes in I'll tape all you
know time really flies with you on the
post it's been so fun this is probably
only funny to us but I don't give a [ __ ]
try it with your friends
well [ __ ] out in the game the game is
called he gets emotional and just
walking to a bar just have one of your
friends start hitting on a woman and
then and the other friends got to go
along yeah and then just start swelling
up and then the other guy goes I'm sorry
he just gets emotional and you just got
to let the other person deal with it
dude you won at the [ __ ] airport we
walked up to that lady at the cup can't
love the little [ __ ] I sell gum
whatever the hell it is excuse me do you
have the I you know one of the biggest
night I broke out here I go hey hey man
what are the biggest condoms you got
what's the biggest size condoms you have
I turn around and walk the one you
turned around and walked away and I'm
just staring at her and I'm biting my
tongue as hard as I can to not laugh and
then I just burst out laughing and she
said what and then when you would repeat
it you wanted to try to point to it I
lost it you lost it and had to walk away
follow a bunch drunk out here you know
one of my favorite things in this
business was Opie from the Opie and
Anthony show was he had this thing that
he would do when guys would start crying
when they would play audio yeah oh my
god was [ __ ] his timing was perfect
every time someone would be talking like
retiring from a sport like when Mike
Schmidt retired which is you know it's
very difficult to watch you strike you
know you know he just was ending his
like 38 years ago a little boy began a
journey to play the wonderful gear up
800 K and that the Pope II would always
go oh boy
what am i favorite it always ugly it
always made oh that's right nobody wants
to see a man just completely you know
what it is I can watch a guy cry if
something terrible is happening just
don't try to talk while you're crying no
that's a thing the talking and then
bursting out into Christ let your
shoulders go yeah mumbles you're [ __ ]
crying but don't [ __ ] for the love of
God a man need O'Brien's how a man needs
to cry in private yeah you do that in
the shower you do it in the shower like
when my son was born
everyone's like did you cry yet and I'm
like no what are you talking about and
then when my son was born it all hit me
later and I went home to go get stuff
for my wife in the hospital i sat on the
couch and I didn't like weep but I just
got I didn't weep but I got emotional
but like just fixing you sit on the
couch by yourself and just use go if
it's stupid it's just completely
unacceptable thank from your podcast
that's unexpressive echt it's
unacceptable dude on it completely hell
you're right though that talked into it
right yeah to talk into it that's that's
what the [ __ ] I'm about crying is you
know yeah you know you always do this to
me you know you always do this to me and
I'm trying my best and then since it's
over yeah it's [ __ ] over but ever my
friends died I've had so many who
[ __ ] died I just cry in the shower
yes what I do I asked a girl we asked a
girl right because you don't feel like
you're crying cuz there's all that water
on your face anyways no we asked the
girl we go what would you do if your
dude started crying like if it wasn't if
nobody died if a dude and you were just
armed he just had a bad day and he just
had a bad day and you got into and he
broke down and cry and she goes yeah no
over over over get the [ __ ] away from me
yeah you know it's funny to some women
they think that they want to see that
part of you they don't get what that is
to them is that's their total conquest
yeah you know when you bang a girl in
the ass you just like yeah I got this
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] with ya their version
was that Jesus built no [ __ ] we did
their version of that is is if they can
get you to be so vulnerable around them
that you cry and
it's one of those things it's always
like when the crowd screams out a joke
they already heard they think they want
to hear it again and then you tell it's
like huh yeah it wasn't as good now the
same thing is that yeah and you said
something you said something about like
if a burglar comes in if you cry in
front of a woman all in her mind is that
what if the burglar comes in on this
[ __ ] guy ya know it's over you can't
cry you strip a woman of security if you
cry in front of her I think I don't
think I've cried if I think my wife so
yeah that's a great is yeah you strip
her of her security cuz nabhi is like
why I got this [ __ ] yeah this foreign
crisis just baby sleeping next to you
every night you know yeah it's it's over
you know that he uh I know you just you
might as I just have a pullover sweater
on you know walking around and then she
mocks you what are you gonna cry [ __ ]
yeah you so mean yeah it's [ __ ] over
dude you can't have that have you ever
have you ever cried alone listening to a
song or like not cried but have you ever
been like oh no I'm completely broken
down and I've told the three cars just
weeping uncontrollably how about you
don't totally cry no no I definitely
teared up listen as an as an artist at
some point you're gonna have to go to
those emotions you need you need to be
you need to be in tune with your
instrument so I have I what was the ones
like I had this weird thing where I
stopped crying at some point I don't
know when I stopped crying and got mad
more when I got hurt and my brother beat
the [ __ ] out of me um you know that with
it most the crying I'd be just like look
at the end of it but I wasn't crying and
then I didn't cry ever one time I
remember one time my brother's bigger
than me my little brother's bigger than
me right big though like it and I
remember he I said I said if you [ __ ]
take my clothes again if you take my
clothes like he did it every day he
would go into my room when you take my
belt you take my clothes and I come home
and I guess in a boy band and I need to
go I need to go out right and I go mom
if he does it again I'm [ __ ] hitting
him ever in my mom be like uh you know
he does any and one time he really
needed a shirt and I'm [ __ ] still
throwing [ __ ] through the house and he
gets out of his friend's car and he
starts
walking up and he's got it on and I
[ __ ] snap them my grandmother was
there and I jumped on him I started
punching him and he stood up but he just
goes [ __ ] you wait you made your older
brother crying on my younger brother oh
he's bigger than me but he didn't know
what to do he got so upset that he just
got and he looked around he just he was
so angry that something needed to come
out and he just goes what did you feel
bad if you start Lana I kind of just
walked away and you know we left about
it afterwards but turned out now he said
he's a [ __ ] he's a big kid but you know
my mom had the opposite I got a little
brother my he's an animal you know no my
mom said she went to she went to a
funeral once and everybody was there and
everybody was crying and she was
overwhelmed with emotion that they had
to [ __ ] drag her out she said she had
them or one of the most embarrassing
things happened to her where she said
she uncontrollably laughed because they
said that that could happen sometimes so
she's sitting there she's she's sitting
there and everybody's crying and like
she went up and she could not stop
laughing and like she and I said why
like and she was like Paul I just don't
know she was I could not stop laughing
and I had to walk me out and like and
she just yeah she said because the
emotions were so much that they said
that could happen sometimes or it just
you just like she didn't know what to do
so instead of just breaking down she
went the other way and just couldn't
couldn't control her say no like humor
like will protect you and really like
that's what they don't get sometimes
when comics make [ __ ] horrific jokes
about some bad event make good jokes
yeah it's about a horrific event so they
go that so [ __ ] mean it's a defense
mechanism itself my mom is it my mom is
a sweetheart who felt bad and her
emotions just went the other way
and she goes Paul I felt so bad if I
couldn't control myself she couldn't
control myself I hate to say this cuz
somebody lost somebody but there was if
there was video of that oh my god pops I
was saying so I somewhere around I don't
know 10 or 11 I didn't cry for years
years and years and years and I didn't I
didn't cry until uh friend of mine
killed himself and even then I was sad
and it's just I went I was in the
bathroom once again yeah and it was in
there and I remember I started to cry
and then I started thinking like wow I'm
crying I haven't cried in a long time
and then I stopped cuz I
because I stopped thinking about the
dude kill himself Wow yeah I went ten
years without a cry and then I had one
what was it over yogurt gummy bears no I
think he might even less I might have
been when my son was born you know I
might have been on my SATs that's
acceptable but I guess it's acceptable
bad guy they just always other than when
I went down at the pool cuz I go down to
the pool I'm down there to me it's
[ __ ] j-law head who's been killing it
in front of me and the lovely Nia and
her cousins it were hang earning cousin
I mean we're hanging out down the pool
and they're doing the usual [ __ ] you
know if you're a redhead and you go down
to the pool like you just asking for
people all you know look out what you
are you know like I never noticed it's
like I'm [ __ ] around myself
I've been around myself since the 60s
the late 60s I know how white I am and
if I ever forget how white I am there's
always somebody there to remind me so I
don't know if you've noticed your skin
tone what am i meditating floating up
out of my body alright so these people
I'm with go come on come on in the pool
like I don't want to go in the pool I
don't want to go in the [ __ ] pool you
know they're like why not why don't you
want to go to the pool you know why cuz
the [ __ ] look look at these people
look at them look at them and you're
getting your you know would you take a
bath without with any one of the people
that you see here these [ __ ] just
messes of human beings there's not
enough chlorine and a [ __ ] pool to
kill whatever the [ __ ] they're dragging
in the pool you know it's like I finally
have gone to the pool then everybody
made fun of how white my [ __ ]
alabaster chest was and then I had to
stay in the shade of the [ __ ] the
lifeguards chair you know you know I had
a show to do I'm being a professional I
can't come out stage later half in the
bag looking like a lobster right I got
to do my little song and dance later on
that night so anyway so I ended up
getting in the [ __ ]
against my what I wanted to do you know
and then I get out of the pool first of
all for my age I am in absolutely
phenomenal top-shelf shape alright I
gotta tell you the [ __ ] just touch
the [ __ ] the humanity that I saw
poolside in Las Vegas the [ __ ]
humanity keyword manatee not this kept
step on on Jim Gaffigan
I just realized he used to use that
reference and I'm pretty sure he used it
I can't remember how the [ __ ] he used it
but if he used it to describe a fat pale
torso not really pale but whatever the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I saw decided that he was
dead on that oh my god is there anything
worse than seeing a tattoo come of age
you know Jesus Christ if you get a
tattoo you better you better just make
the mental decision that you're gonna
p90x for the rest of your [ __ ] life
cuz when you don't dude I saw this guy
down at the pool all right
he had like not only the worst tattoos
you've ever seen in your life like the
worst placement you know what I mean
like you get one like on the side of
your arm up by your shoulder that looks
good right on the bicep that looks good
you know Joe somebody gets one right
over there Voicebox
like I don't give a [ __ ] what you have
surrounding that that leads into that
part of the work or the piece whatever
they call it looks [ __ ] horrible leg
tattoos horrific horrific so this
[ __ ] jerk-off he has basically the
exact sort of like tribal thing that the
rock has except he doesn't look tribal
he looks like an accountant you know and
he doesn't work out so just imagine if
the rock was his pasty as I was
and it never worked down in his life but
has that same tattoo that starts at the
elbow goes up the arm over the shoulder
and covers one whole PEC but the way
this guy had it done was it didn't cover
his whole packet came swinging in and
went right above his his man nipple so
now all of that all of that is like
colored in so because of the paste enos
of his torso your eye is just drawn to
his right nipple is he standing in the
[ __ ] pool my neck was sore from
shaking my head at people it was it was
absolutely [ __ ] horrific right so so
anyways I go back up to the I go back up
to the hotel room right you know gonna
make sure that I'm all shipshape for my
goddamn show and I put on the news and
what do they end up doing a story about
they start doing a story about the
amount of fecal matter found in public
pools right after I just got out of a
goddamn pool you know and I know people
always think I'll stay away from where
the kids are stay away from the kiddie
pool right stay away from that they
always blame the [ __ ] kids well I you
know something after seeing what I saw a
poolside you know there weren't a lot of
kids in there but I guarantee you
somebody got a coli I know this is
[ __ ] disgusting but people you
basically bathing you don't see even
more [ __ ] up is Vegas is just like you
know people fly in from all over the
world you're taking a [ __ ] AIDS bath
you know with a shot of [ __ ] what the
hell is that [ __ ] that came out but it
killed people so fast that it just
burned out nobody just ran into the
woods the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] called ah
Christ I can't remember
Ebola that's it with a shot of Ebola or
whatever food poisoning I don't know
what it is a Salmonella shower whatever
the [ __ ] you want to call it I'm done
with public pools the only pool that I
will ever
woman again is my pool if I ever get one
or the pool of some hot chick that I
want to [ __ ] bang because I have
Nia's permission that's the only way
it's going to go down other than that
you know
I'll just go I'll just go take a bath
[Laughter]
that way I'm out of the Sun you know
I'll take a couple of vitamin E pills
whatever the [ __ ] it is you get from the
Sun other than skin cancer I'm done with
it you know what America needs to
implement after years and years of
calling the French people smelly you
know that's kind of like the thing when
we went over to France and save their
ass for the second time last century oh
wait did we do it once we did it one
time right I can't [ __ ] remember
so anyways we've always made fun of the
French father
they smell if you ever watched Bugs
Bunny growing up man you saw Pepe LePew
if you noticed he had a French accent
you know that's the kind of [ __ ] you
couldn't get away with today because of
political correctness I guess they were
basically saying that you know but they
stunk but I'll tell you one thing that
the French have when it comes to hygiene
over Americans all right is the bidet
all right I can guarantee you if I ever
go swimming in a public pool again it's
going to be at France unless there's a
bunch of Americans I I've been over to
England I never saw a bidet over there
you know but des is basically a car wash
for your [ __ ] and you know it leaves
you feeling refreshed puts a [ __ ]
smile on your face and evidently in
France she's so [ __ ] happy you forget
to put on deodorant but I'll tell you
right now you can jump in that pool I
bet they're not dead but they're not
talking about that [ __ ] over there right